hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to spore with Wade here say
hi Wade hey guys hey guys and we decided
to play this game that was locked time
reflect America cut that was often
requested by you guys so we're finally
playing it on I side it would be more
fun to play together because one of my
favorite game from series of all times
is Spore I showed it to him it's every
time I want to show someone a hilarious
less blood on YouTube I picked Spore
because that is one of the funniest
thing if you haven't seen it go watch
the game guys version right now it'll be
a lot funnier than this one so let's go
alright spore is a God sim meaning that
you start from the tiniest infinitesimal
I like micro why the red one well I mean
it looks like we'd be swimming in blood
well no I guess not but I mean it's okay
we have in mind well I don't have any
idea you're the band playing in balls
balls the planet balls the planet why
would it just be balls why wouldn't it
be balls okay if you oh that is blood
red is blood we here on boy boy are we
actually okay it's blue now all the
sudden if that makes any sense at all so
anyway we are starting out as our first
little microorganism growth beautiful
little creatures evolve oh yes okay so
you click to swim around so click in the
area you'll go in that direction yes you
want that in your mouth that's me yeah
get those fart bubbles - what are the
purples do they give you absolutely not
to kill that thing
okay going for it going for it
what's that thing kill that oh look at
all his eyes oh well we did it now eat
him eat eat all his meat - yes oh how
many we're coming to meet in our mouths
jokes I'm gonna make in this okay sure I
know well okay this little fellow is the
truth of life here Maddox dead he died
he died a horrible death and you watched
it happen what do you do anything no we
didn't do anything to help but you want
that that's a new part that you could
use don't get okay well you gotta hit
the check boxes and boxes our side of
the screw what do I care what you see
click on it little guys growing up real
quick you need more meat what does this
green pinup plants that's uh clients I
guess you could eat that if you sure eat
is meat consuming we actually do the
live stream just yesterday we're both
talking about how our voice is heard but
right now my is that that weird point
where both hurts but is that really
ridiculously a little guy come here
wayde's currently going to kill the
little innocent little thingy over there
oh yes
I'm so much bigger bite an audience in
one bite he's consumed the entirety of
that creature yes you can
oh yes you can and at any moment you
could also make a baby
you did it you killed it yes you could
not us personally no not between the two
of us we could not make a baby blanket
make one out here die if you wanted to
if you really really want to do what
well maybe you do I'm not saying you
don't but if you want to need you know
your baby at any time die so quickly I'm
pretty good okay all right you just make
a baby you're growing too big oh yeah
any more than you unless you're the
female are you the me male uh yes okay
so what you're gonna have to do here is
we're gonna make our creature this is
where everything comes to pass okay so
we got our new part there we got our
mouth so you only have a certain amount
of DNA that you could spend down there
you have to do is you have to make this
guy the coolest you can now I'm leaving
everything up to you the only rule is
you can't make it look like a penis that
joke has been done forever and ever and
ever okay don't make it look like a
penis
can't help but notice this is awfully
dick like maybe spikes on the rear so
that nothing could sneak it yeah yeah
yeah right that way anything they tried
to get up no way we've got a really
horny boy if you get like the forties
but everyone we're gonna be attracted by
your big butt and then they're gonna be
stabbed in the eyes but I like it I like
it I like where this is going yeah all
right do we need a furry bonus that's a
filter mouth that's not a butt but you
could also get front but front spike
okay you good name your guy what's his
name name our species
great another point spiky but but you
know I think yeah I think actually the
eyes the eyes should be farther back bay
leaves you alright cuz you need a better
perspective they can't see anything that
close so the eyes need to be back here
on the button that's a nice look if the
eyes are an attractive part of
everything so you need to be able to
lure people in with the eyes Oh get him
with sexy eyes it's one of the eyelashes
a brilliant come here big boy look at my
big front but with my eyes on it and
then they get hit by the spikes and they
don't know what hit them they died
yes he died exactly alright get your own
control again glad I could put my
expertise in there my hair situation
today I don't think you know the Devon
is beautiful there can we kill this yeah
you can try will do get him stab them
really quickly I am a beast actually you
got another part that you can put on
your species they're good but we need to
breed again no not yet you just you just
bread do you really need another
breeding well yes
no he's gonna steal your meat get your
meat in your mouth before he puts his
meat in your mouth tell me you're
meeting his mouth he's got a faster
jelly you got what's called a flagellum
what jellivision knows that those
pincers oh that's a big guy forget you
don't want to mess with that guy you I
you can't even get close to that guy
good guys whoa okay you know those guys
that I was telling you about their God
but you've heard him kill him well
you're not fast enough fastest way way
faster okay but maybe now you're gonna
try turn around he's gonna run into Dow
something down you stuck on the other
way always stuck yeah get a medium yeah
those are too old
oh you got it Oh get all the food you're
gonna you're gonna even kill that guy
I'm gonna do it actually he's got a
pocus sucker in you and suck all the
meat that you okay come on turn get the
meat now okay you can made again call
okay call sexy times get away from me
Sam doll you know what's weird I know I
said now we're the bigger man I know
that we were saying we weren't gonna
make it big I can't help but notice this
is awfully predictable it's just a big
bun there's two orbs on the back of it
but you did that I didn't well I do you
did everything
Oh what is this no that's a jet that's
very fast but this one also makes you
can turn so you need to sell stuff to be
able to get stuff we're gonna keep our
spiky but don't we yeah we can keep our
spiky but what we don't necessarily
neither spiky front that's true we do
need a mouth but we can get the cilia to
make some speed fast aerodynamic go
quick
oh is this still is that still falling
now it's gonna mustache it's got a dick
mustache it looked even more phallic
without those spikes there but I think
those help okay that helps here so that
oh that's good that looks
you know that looks good yeah and he's
got aerodynamics ISM I like it okay go
wait name it again what's this all we do
is give it fins so we'll call it turn
fast II I like it turn fast e10 turb
turb faster faster fast turbo turbo fast
no not turbo but turn fast ease that's
nasty I like it it's the 90s we really
bring closer so good oh are the colors
horses are you a little bit oh I
apologize that's all right go oh let's
go it's the same place it was behind Jim
you're going throws me off it's the same
please
shows himself bubbles Wow my ears is it
oh look at this oh he can't get away due
to fans for them whoa whoa anyways yeah
we're gonna get you well please you'll
only what if I'm gonna get shotgun
another personality oh I'm so dead come
on look he killed you you're dead geisha
that kept the front came over so now
what
you couldn't even afford the front class
he was about to run what did you do you
had him on the ropes he's let him kill
you do something there's a little guy
kill him people kill him kill him kill
yes blood glorious anakata
don't wait why didn't we name it
anaconda we got the great big butt oh
yeah but we need to make sure that them
by using Oh kill those guys their fight
run away from that guy yeah
kill that big guy you sure
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
proboscis proboscis we need it that's
Toby Turner's version of this anyway
enough points to do much rid of
something yeah you gotta get rid of
something it's always a give and take
what is this thing for that's your
smooth Minh thing but you also have
other movement things so you may not
need that yeah we don't get out okay so
you got rid of that we don't need that
we got a mouth why is it in mice or more
speed oh you know I like how bulbous
that is yeah well maybe we need a back
poison spitter you know cuz we do all oh
they're right nestled protect the eyes
you know have the poison and spikes eyes
there's that way it's on the I ever see
something oh that is beautiful
yeah I screwed up I screwed up
Oh God Oh God they're large then oh yes
that's good
oh no anaconda don't want this no no and
I kind of want this tall and his name is
now anaconda trap her friend Jesse's
technique and that's serious when we
were used to go to bars alone he had
this strategy he always said that any
girl at a bar was automatically just a
skank like the dirtiest girl ever like
not wife material but he had this
technique called the penis flytrap where
he would not go up and talk to anyone
and would literally just sit like a lump
on the bar
[Music]
oh you're so fast
like your butt large are flippers
I like your plumes of poison yeah so big
weird
pretty pretty they're pretty no I'm not
trying at all I'll steal this meat whoa
look it's your friend you're the you're
becoming the dominant species die
[Music]
was nothing to us he's got electricity
but electric an electric fire good ball
laughter you got the good job okay so we
need to make it available on me we need
to make a baby and get elected
okay electric buddies we do that right
now do it
what the [ __ ] now dead serious dunno I'm
dead serious dude right now may not
joking easy here mate he's dead from the
poison he deserves discussing species
with all the poison but guys go hanim
with sexy eyes we're murderers come here
sick my fart poison cloud ahead well you
gotta get rid of so ease in get rid of
spikes
I like the poisonous spikes can't be
bigger than that that's all you make -
can you make it double well stop being
an idiot about it okay give me the mouse
you're dogging no oh oh you got it okay
okay we don't need to see any of we can
see fine okay no oh I'll make the mouth
bigger - big head on my thing or is that
look good knob oh I think it's very does
it look good we need - does it look good
time - does it look good oh I don't even
think they can see her sexy eyes when
silly whoa we're I think she
get on - nothing is lasting against you
I think you can take on that guy sure
yeah go for I don't hit his bike giving
you the I like your sexy eyes okay kill
that guy you're so slow I know we lost
your flagellum and now you're not seeing
their speed at least you're electricity
oh oh they're trying to kill your guy
don't let him kill your guy letting him
kill your guy try not to stop hitting
their spikes your again they were spill
something you dingus you steal to me you
keep right on spike but kill him yes
Thomas get on it
he's took get him from the behind spoke
his butt with your penis mouths they
can't know that's the spider can you
steal to me
just forget it still to me you let him
bite you just whisperer
whatever okay so you're big now eat him
up chomp oh we're so so we are so so
slow they do evolve to get more speed no
just stopping so gosh darn slow let's
kill that guy yes yes no get them with
your poison bud
time to die eat it meemaw get them
what's that thing in a distance there's
Derby eyes one really really cool
that's the CMC's we strive to be he got
punched
don't put his [ __ ] you're gonna die
baby get your juices you're killed by a
baby that's true baby again are you
gonna die no it's bad give me that means
I'm not a bad good okay there's another
egg you want to kill it you literally
were going right to that egg why did you
turn around and go to a different one
cuz I want stop showing up here but okay
they're both dead yeah that's what the
boys gave me the me that's what the
elected me me Oh too big for me again
[Music]
that guy shouldn't be alive he'll kill
him coming he's weak and insignificant
you kill him and eat him yes yes
we get the meat first we're almost
finally out of this stage all right no
oh wait no don't do that don't do that
killer eat him kill his eggs first
yay
yeah if we murdered everything ass
what's happening right now we have a
brain holy crap Oh feel pretty smart
okay then
congratulations you're on the path to
sentence why should we advance yes we
should evolve legs and go to land but we
should save that for the next episode
that okay I was excited thank you all so
much for thank you also thank you all so
much for watching we are going to play
more spore if you guys wanted to let us
know what you guys want us to do in the
next episode we don't care because we
won't see it cuz we're only recording
this now so thanks again everybody for
watching and as always we will see you
[Music]
No